grohe miles are very important almost in
any culture with respect to two young
people the first quality is person needs
to be attractive attractive person gains
a lot of attention and that's what is
required of a role model but the best
thing I like it in my role model it's
he's a human more than anything else he
made a mistake he can share his mistake
and he's the life the second quality is
the person needs to be charismatic
there's a desperate need for role models
would lead the region to the path of
success and will inspire people living
in it third quality which which is the
role model needs to be representing the
group and not representing themselves we
need a leader unrelated of our own
generation so I think by having such
sugar and water that's going to bring a
big revolution in the sense that it will
get bring up a lot of talent to improve
very least the last and final quality
which is dedication perseverance strong
morals and good character the desire and
determination for global peace
inequality and environmental and
economic awareness so what we want to do
is essentially create role models to
show that used even in a young age can
actually achieve raising the bar because
short so the Middle East can actually be
in the global picture of accomplishments
and achievements